Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, I'm going to continue
talking about renal physiology
today;
again, this is covered in
Chapter 9.
You will have noticed as you're
reading Chapter 9 that there's
more covered than just renal
physiology there.
It also talks about
biotransformations and the role
of the liver in getting rid of
substances.
We're not going to cover that
part in class but I encourage
you to read it as a whole to get
a broader perspective of how
kidney function fits into the
overall ability of your body to
maintain what we call
homeostasis or a constant
environment.
As I talked about last
time, one of the important
elements of this constant
environment is to maintain
sodium,
potassium, bicarbonate,
and the levels of other key
molecules at a constant level
throughout the day and
throughout your life.
It does that--and you're able
to do that not by regulating how
much you eat of those things,
but they kidney does that for
you by sensing what
concentrations are in your body,
keeping what you need and
getting rid of what you don't
need.
We started talking about how
the kidney is able to accomplish
this remarkable task.
Hopefully, the main point I
wanted to make in the last
lecture was how grateful you
ought to be that your kidneys do
function properly,
because as one of the results
of that is that you only have to
produce about 1 L or 1.5 L of
urine per day to get rid of all
the waste products that are
produced by metabolism in your
body.
Without that concentrating
ability of your kidney,
I mean the ability of the
kidney to produce a urine that's
very concentrated in waste
rather than dilute in waste,
you only have to relief
yourselves of 1.5 L of fluid
everyday instead of the 100 or
so liters that you'd have to in
the absence of that ability to
concentrate.
That makes possible a lot of
the things that we enjoy in life
like sitting through a 50 minute
lecture.
What I want to talk about
today is some of how the kidney
does that and I'm going to go
back a few steps because I
covered a lot.
I wanted to give you an
overview at the end of sort of
the last half of the lecture
last time,
about how the nephron functions
and I'm going to go back now and
step through it a little bit
more slowly and talk about some
of the details.
Now, the--like the other
systems we've talked about the
brain, the heart,
the circulatory system,
the kidney has a very sort of
rich and complex physiology
which now we understand fairly
well.
We're only going to scratch the
surface of that and if you get
excited about it,
there are ways for you to learn
more in your time here at Yale
and certainly beyond.
This is a picture that I
showed you before,
sort of to orient you again;
I have this picture of a kidney
lying on its side.
It's a layered structure,
the outer layer or the sort of
shell around the outside of the
kidney,
this fibrous capsule which sort
of distinguishes what's inside
the kidney from what's outside
the kidney,
the layer below that is called
the cortex, the inner layers
that have these sort of
striations is called the
medulla.
All of this comes together in
this region here called the
renal pelvis,
this region where the renal
artery enters,
the renal vein leaves,
and the ureter exits the kidney
as well.
Everything collects sort of
at--what's at the bottom of this
diagram but it would be on the
inside or medial surface of the
kidney and it's in its anatomic
position.
I mentioned last time that
the functional units of the
kidney are this structure called
a nephron.
Each kidney has about a million
of these nephrons and that
they're oriented within these
layers,
so a nephron is going to sit
sort of this axis here,
going up and down in this
diagram.
That's the reason why I turned
this kidney on its side so when
you look at the nephron here you
can think about it sitting in
this orientation in the kidney.
Of course, the kidney has this
sort of curved structure so the
nephrons are going to sort of
radiate out from the central
portion through the medulla and
up into the cortex,
with the glomerulus near the
cortex, and the Loop of Henle
stretching down into the
medulla.
I also mentioned several
features of the nephron.
One is the glomerulus where the
place where filtration takes
place, this tuft of capillaries
that's surrounded by a capsule.
The capsule is there to catch
this filtrate that's produced by
high pressure inside the
arteriole system forcing some
fluid out through these leaky
capillaries.
The capsule,
called Bowman's capsule,
is there to catch this fluid
and start it on its way through
this series of tubules.
I talked about different
regions of the tubules,
the proximal convoluted tubule,
proximal because it's near the
glomerulus, the Loop of Henle,
this structure that stretches
down through the cortex into the
medulla and then back up again,
and the distal convoluted
tubule which is farther from the
glomerulus and empties into the
collecting duct which then moves
down through the cortex,
through the medulla,
and into this region of the
renal pelvis where all the
collecting ducts empty into the
ureter and then onto the
bladder.
A filtrate of plasma is
produced here in the glomerulus
and as this filtrate of plasma,
this fluid that is going to be
urine at some point,
moves through this series of
tubules,
it gets processed,
it gets modified,
it gets changed.
In particular,
the cells of these tubules are
able to reabsorb the molecules
that you need.
They reabsorb a lot of water,
they reabsorb a lot of sodium,
potassium, bicarbonate,
and they do that without
reabsorbing a lot of the waste
products you don't need like
urea;
as you might guess given this
configuration that there's some
interplay between the activities
that happen at different parts
of the tubule.
That is, if sodium is being
reabsorbed in the proximal
tubule, which it is,
then where does that sodium go?
It's pumped out of the tubule
and into the space around--into
the space of the kidney
surrounding it and so sodium is
going to accumulate out here.
Now, where does that sodium
go?
Well, eventually it's going to
back into the blood so there
must be a lot of blood vessels
around there as well.
They're not shown in this
diagram;
they'll be shown in the next
one.
This sodium leaves the urine
through the walls of the tubules
and is reabsorbed back into
blood vessels.
That leaves some sodium out
here in this space,
and one of the really
interesting things about the
kidney,
which we won't be--about the
nephron, in particular,
that we won't be able to talk
about in so much detail,
is how one part of its tubule
system uses the result of the
other in order to establish
gradients to produce this
concentrated urine.
We're not really going to talk
about that but I wanted to
mention it on this diagram here,
that there are real important
reasons why the tubules are
arranged in the anatomical
pattern that they are.
An additional thing,
which I mentioned last time,
is that if you looked,
as cell biologists did,
at the cells that make up these
linings of these tubules,
you'd find that they look
different in different parts of
the nephron.
This has to do with their
different functions.
Some are very good at
reabsorbing sodium,
some are very good at
reabsorbing water,
and some are good at other
functions.
The function of each--of these
groups of cells that make up
different portions of the tubule
is critical for overall nephron
function.
I'll say a little bit about
that just to give you a flavor
for how that happens without
talking too much about the
details.
This shows a collection of
nephrons, sort of in a more
complex arrangement.
I've got the kidney here so you
can be reminded again that this
might be a structure that comes
from here and then you can see
several nephrons.
In particular,
there's a lot of glomeruli in
this picture where the nephron
that's associated with this
glomerulus and this glomerulus
aren't shown so that we can
focus on just a few of them.
Just to give you a sense for
these million nephrons that are
arranged in the kidney,
they have their glomeruli at
different locations,
up and down,
they are surrounded by their
proximal and distal convoluted
tubules,
and these Loops of Henle
stretch down into the medullary
region and then come back up.
I wanted to use this more
complicated diagram to sort of
illustrate the flow.
How does fluid move through
this--through one particular
nephron within this system here,
and so I hope this comes out.
Did you see the red arrow up
here?
That red arrow represents
arteriole flow of blood and this
is a branch of the renal artery
which is serving this whole
collection of nephrons that are
here.
Of course that vessel branches,
at some point,
and here I show a branch of a
branch,
which is heading up towards
these glomeruli up in this upper
region of the cortex.
Blood is flowing through these
branches of the renal artery
into the substance of the kidney
and it flows up into a
glomerulus here.
Now, because this is not
too distant a branch from the
aorta pressure is still high
here.
You know that pressure remains
pretty high until you get down
to the arteriole levels;
we learned that when we talked
about the circulatory system.
The pressure here is fairly
high, it might be 70 or 80
millimeters of mercury.
This is the pressure that
drives filtration in the
glomerulus.
The green arrow,
which just appeared up here,
is supposed to indicate for
this glomerulus right there
filtration happens.
Because of the pressure drop in
the glomerulus,
the low pressure in Bowman's
space,
this space that surrounds it,
fluid is driven through the
walls of the capillary and
collected outside.
What is produced there is
really, what I called last time,
an ultra-filtrate of plasma.
That is the urine or the
filtrate that's going to become
urine, at this point,
would be identical to plasma in
composition except all of the
big items are removed;
all the large molecules,
all the cells are removed,
other than that it's identical.
The concentration of sodium in
the filtrate is the same as the
concentration of sodium in the
plasma,
concentration of urea same as
concentration of the plasma,
concentration of bicarbonate
and so on.
As long as any molecule that's
below that cut off it's going to
have the same concentration as
it is in plasma,
so there this green arrow
represents filtration.
From there the fluid moves
through the distal convoluted
tubules, which you can't really
see here, but it's up in this
portion.
The white, if you can see on
the--here some of these are
white and some of them are blue.
The white ones are the proximal
convoluted tubule but they're
really not like in the diagram
before,
these convoluted tubule are
sort of mixed together,
they interact with one another.
This filtrate goes through the
proximal convoluted tubule down
in the Loop of Henle and now you
can see--follow these green
arrows,
it's moving down,
it takes a turn deep in the
medulla and starts coming back
up again and heads back up to
the distal convoluted tubule.
Now, we're not going to
talk about it at all in this
class, but if you go on to study
physiology,
one of the most amazing things
about the nephron is its--is
that this loop allows the
nephron to create a gradient of
osmolarity within the tissue
outside the nephrons in the
kidney.
It's able to create a
concentration gradient of sodium
basically, but of ions that it
can then use to reabsorb water.
Austin, who was sitting in the
front last time,
mentioned that she thought
osmosis was an important part of
how the kidney works and it is.
Osmotic forces are how water
concentration--how water moves
around in the kidney.
The kidney is able to regulate
how concentrated or how dilute
your urine is by using osmotic
gradients and those osmotic
gradients are established in the
Loop of Henle.
It's really a remarkable sort
of biophysical process that
you'll learn about if you study
more renal physiology.
There's a reason why the fluid
goes down and goes up and it's
to establish these gradients
which the kidney uses to
concentrate or extract water
from the urine.
This orange area here
represents the flow going from
the distal convoluted tubule
back into the collecting duct
and down through the collecting
duct and eventually into the
ureter.
This is just a more complicated
diagram of what I've told you
already and it's--I encourage
you to sort of walk through it
and look at all the parts so you
have a sense for how the anatomy
of the kidney works.
This picture I showed you
before, just to remind you of
the first step in producing
urine, is filtration.
I've talked about it several
times now but there's this tuft
of capillaries which sits inside
this capsule called Bowman's
capsule.
There's an artery which feeds
blood in, called the afferent
arteriole.
'Afferent' means towards so
it's the arteriole that's
carrying blood towards the
glomerulus,
and the efferent arteriole
which carries the blood out of
the glomerulus.
Now, the flow rates here would
be different;
the blood that's flowing
through the--the amount of blood
flowing through the afferent
arteriole and the amount flowing
through the efferent arteriole,
'efferent' meaning away from,
are different because some
fluid is lost.
That's the amount that's
filtered into Bowman's space.
We talked about last time
that these are both arterioles
and that because they're
arterioles they can constrict or
reduce their diameters and
expand,
dilate or expand their
diameters.
Because of this,
if it constricts then the
pressure drop over that length
of arteriole is going to change.
Having these two adjustable
resistances on both sides of the
glomerulus allows each nephron
to regulate what the pressure is
in the fluid inside the
capillaries of the glomerulus.
Now, since its pressure inside
these capillaries which is the
driving force for filtration,
that means that each nephron
has the ability to adjust how
much is filtered in each
glomerulus.
Now, if--we're going to--in
a slide or two going to talk
about a concept called the
glomerular filtration rate.
This is a concept that's
defined for your whole kidneys
and the glomerular filtration
rate,
we all have a glomerular
filtration rate,
it's the rate at which filtrate
is being produced in all the
glomeruli of our kidneys.
It's the rate at which the
fluid that's going to become
urine is produced.
It's an important measure of
how well your kidney is
functioning, is how much
filtrate it's producing per
minute.
What I want to emphasize on
this diagram here that another
remarkable thing about the
function of the kidney is that
each of these individual million
or two million nephrons are able
to adjust their individual
filtration rate by changing the
pressure within the glomerulus.
Of course this was a picture I
showed you last time of the
actual filtration membrane,
the surface of these
capillaries where this pressure
drop acts and through which
large things are filtered out.
Here's a cartoon of the
glomerulus and this cartoon
actually shows several things.
One it shows the arteriole,
the afferent arteriole that's
coming in and the afferent
arteriole that's going out and
so here's the tuft of
capillaries that make up the
glomerulus.
Here's Bowman's space,
which is ready to catch the
filtrate.
This first arrow here
represents the filtrate that's
produced in the glomerulus of
this particular nephron.
Now, after that filtrate's
produced it starts to flow
through the proximal convoluted
tubule and then through the Loop
of Henle,
and the distal convoluted
tubule, and eventually the
collecting duct,
and as we know from last time,
several things can happen.
One is that molecules within
this fluid can be reabsorbed,
and if they're reabsorbed they
move out of the tubular system
and into--back into blood.
That's why there are blood
vessels surrounding all the
nephrons in the kidneys,
so that there's a blood flow
that's ready to catch these
molecules as they're reabsorbed
from the tubules.
We also mentioned that
there are some special processes
of secretion so that the blood
vessels in the kidney are smart
enough to detect some molecules
and secrete them actively into
the urine.
Then, whatever is not
reabsorbed, plus what's
secreted, is what ends up in the
urine after it flows through all
the tubules.
What's different here is then
instead of showing the complex
geometry of the tubules,
this just shows a tube which is
going to the bladder down here.
This diagram is simplified
because I wanted to just talk
about one concept and that's
this glomerular filtration rate,
the rate at which fluid is
produced in the glomeruli of all
of the kidneys.
The question is how would
you measure this glomerular
filtration rate in people?
If it's an important measure of
kidney function how would you
measure it?
It turns out that physiologists
have learned how to measure it
by taking advantage of a
particular molecule called
inulin.
Inulin is a molecule that's not
a normal part of our diet,
it's a polysaccharide,
but it's a polysaccharide that
is of sort of intermediate
molecular weight.
I think it's about 1,000 or
2,000 in molecular weight,
but your body doesn't know how
to digest it.
If you get inulin in your
blood, it just circulates and
isn't changed at all,
but it's small enough that it's
filtered in the glomerulus.
If there's inulin in the blood
then it gets filtered through
the glomerulus and ends up in
the ultra-filtrate.
Another remarkable property
about inulin is that it's not
reabsorbed.
There's no reason for your body
to reabsorb it because it's not
something you can really use and
you don't need it,
and it's not actively secreted,
so whatever gets filtered ends
up in the urine.
This molecule turns out to be a
convenient tool that physicians
can use to measure your
glomerular filtrate rate in the
event that they want to test
your kidney function.
How would you do that?
You would inject an amount of
inulin into the blood and you
would measure how much--what's
the concentration of inulin in
the plasma?
You would inject some amount of
inulin and you'd measure how
much of it is in the plasma.
You'd then wait over some
period of time and you would
collect the urine and you'd
measure how much of that inulin
appears in the urine.
Now, since inulin is
neither reabsorbed nor secreted,
however many molecules of
inulin are filtered at the
glomerulus has to be the same as
the number of molecules that
enter the urine.
It's not reabsorbed,
it's not secreted,
so whatever number of molecules
enter here they have to leave
here.
So, if I know the concentration
of inulin in the urine I know
how much urine is produced over
some period of time,
I know the concentration in the
plasma.
Remember that one of the
features of this ultra-filtrate
is that it just cuts off in
molecular weight but whatever
concentration--if you're below
that molecular weight,
whatever concentration is in
the plasma is the same as the
initial concentration in the
ultra-filtrate,
and so the plasma inulin
concentration is the same here.
If I just do a simple
accounting for all the inulin,
whatever the glomerular
filtration rate is times the
concentration in the plasma has
to equal whatever the
concentration in the urine is
times the rate of urine
production.
I can measure in a person
how much urine they're producing
per time, you can measure the
concentration of inulin in the
urine,
you can measure the
concentration in the blood and
so you can calculate the
glomerular filtration rate.
This is a method that takes
advantage of the unique
properties of this molecule
inulin.
This is a--physician's use this
general strategy in a variety of
ways to measure flow rates of
things inside your body that are
difficult to measure directly
and they do that by looking at
what's called a tracer molecule.
In this case,
insulin is a tracer.
It's picked for its particular
properties, that it's filtered
freely in the glomerulus but
neither reabsorbed nor secreted.
It allows you to calculate some
physiological function sort of
deep inside your body,
so you can measure glomerular
filtration rate this way.
I've already showed you
this picture that shows the
vascular system of the kidney,
sort of laid out in a line
here.
Here's the renal artery
branching into afferent
arterioles, branching into
glomerular capillaries,
back into efferent arterioles
and then to the capillaries that
surround the tubules,
and the pressure drops that are
associated with that.
I show it just to remind you of
how the kidney could regulate
its glomerular filtration rate
by changing the diameters of
either the efferent or afferent
arteriole.
Changing the resistances,
changing the relative pressure
drops along the kidney
vasculature,
and therefore regulating the
important level which is here
how much pressure is in the
glomerulus to drive filtration.
I've talked about this
several times now,
and I think if you study the
diagram and read the text
hopefully that will make sense
to you.
It is--this pressure is what
drives inside the glomerulus the
flow of filtrate and the
production of filtrate that
becomes urine.
What happens after this point?
What happens are these two
processes that we've talked
about that make the kidney
different from a simple filter.
Filtration is an important part
of its function,
that's easy to understand from
sort of an engineering
perspective.
You produce this
ultra-filtrate,
and then the kidney works very
hard to recover the molecules
that you need so that you don't
have to produce a large volume
of urine in order to get rid of
the waste.
It does that by two processes,
reabsorption and secretion,
which I've already mentioned,
and we're really going to focus
mainly on reabsorption for the
rest of the time here today.
In reabsorption the key
elements of reabsorption are
reabsorption of water or return
of much of this volume of water
that's filtered at the
glomerulus and recovery of
solutes that are needed like
sodium and potassium and
bicarbonate.
This table just sort of
tells you in general what
happens at different portions of
the nephron.
Filtration happens in Bowman's
capsule, I think I've said
enough about that one.
Selective reabsorption happens
in all other elements of the
tubules, the proximal,
the Loop of Henle,
and the distal convoluted
tubule.
How does selective reabsorption
happen?
It happens by the physical
processes of diffusion or just
the movement of molecules down
concentration gradients,
and it also happens by active
transport.
We talked about active
transport earlier.
We talked--for example when we
were talking about the action
potential, we talked about this
active transport system that's
able to shuttle sodium and
potassium molecules across
membranes.
So, most cells in the body
have this active transport
system called the sodium
potassium pump,
or the sodium potassium ATPase.
Its main function is to bring
sodium from inside the cell,
pump it out,
take potassium from outside the
cell and pump it in.
As a result of the action of
this pump that's what creates
this normal state that you have
high extracellular sodium
concentrations and high
intracellular potassium
concentrations.
If that pump wasn't working,
then sodium would diffuse from
outside to in because the
concentration is higher outside
than inside,
and potassium would diffuse
from inside to out because the
concentration is higher inside
than outside.
Now, this pump is driven by
ATP.
ATP is a molecule,
it's one of the end--it's a
molecule that's produced when we
metabolize sugars and get energy
from them.
We store them in the form of
ATP, and then the body uses ATP
to do things like operate this
pump.
A lot of the ATP that you're
using right now in your body is
being used to maintain the
concentration of sodium high
outside your cells and potassium
high inside your cells.
Why are you spending so much
energy doing that?
Why would your body spend so
much energy trying to maintain
these differences of ion
concentrations?
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Because these
concentrations have to exist for
cellular functions like--?
Like the generation of action
potentials in the nervous
system, like the generation of
action potentials in the heart
that drive contraction and
beating of the heart.
Without these differences of
concentration you could neither
send nerve impulses,
your heart would not beat;
maintains life and lots of the
activities of life and so a lot
of energy goes into producing
them.
In those same kinds of
processes are used in the kidney
to shuttle ions from one place
to another, I'll show you an
example of that in a minute.
Reabsorption of water,
I tried to emphasize last time
how important reabsorption of
water is,
because you have to produce a
lot of filtrate in order to
collect a lot of waste products.
You got to produce a lot of
filtrate in order to get a lot
of urea into the urine.
You don't want to lose that
much water because any water you
lose you have to drink to
recover from.
Reabsorption of water is a very
important process that happens
in the kidney,
it happens in all the tubular
segments.
Secretion happens mainly in the
distal convoluted tubule,
and as I mentioned,
we're not going to say very
much about that.
If we were just able to
look and take one nephron and
take that complicated series of
tubes that I showed you in
diagrams before and stretch it
out while it still is
functioning,
and then measure as a function
of distance along this
complicated tubule,
what's the concentration or
relative concentration of some
of these key molecules we're
talking about?
What we would see is shown in
this diagram here.
Now, I mention this special
property in inulin,
that it's neither reabsorbed or
secreted,
and that's shown here by this
flat line, so whatever gets
filtered in the glomerulus,
at the glomerulus,
that number of molecules
remains in the urine throughout
its progress through the
tubules.
That's why you can use it as a
tracer to measure GFR (glomerula
filtration rate) because it's
neither reabsorbed in any of
these tubules nor secreted,
so the number of molecules that
come out in the filtrate,
that's the number that leave in
the urine.
That's not true for glucose.
I mentioned yesterday that
glucose is not normally found in
urine.
When you do find glucose in the
urine of an individual that
indicates that there's some
disease process going on and
that's because glucose is very
efficiently reabsorbed in the
proximal tubule.
If I just looked at
concentration within the
filtrate, within the urine
through the proximal tubule,
there'd be a lot of glucose
here and that concentration
drops as we move through the
proximal tubule such that
there's no glucose in the
filtrate by the time we get to
the end of the proximal tubule.
That's one of the simpler
cases, that glucose is just
reabsorbed in the proximal
tubule.
Sodium, on the other hand,
has a much more complicated
pattern.
That sodium concentration drops
as you move through the proximal
tubule so a lot of that sodium
is reabsorbed,
about two-thirds of it is
reabsorbed in the proximal
tubule.
Then, if I looked over the Loop
of Henle in the descending loop,
the loop that goes down,
actually sodium molecules come
back in, and then sodium
molecules go back out in the
ascending loop.
This has to do with the
establishment of gradients of
sodium that I mentioned before
in the interstitial space which
allows the kidney to--this
represents those--the sodium
that's used to create those
gradients,
those gradients are used for
water absorption.
Then, most of the rest of the
kidney is--the rest of the
sodium is cleaned up or
recovered in the distal tubule
and the collecting tubules.
Urea, which has this pattern
here, a lot reabsorbed but then
it comes back out again,
and then it's reabsorbed
finally.
Now, some of these things are
going to be hard for you to
understand why they go in and
out.
It has to do with this complex
interplay that I mentioned
before between processes that
are happening in different parts
of the tubule,
establishing gradients that are
then used in different portions
to aid in reabsorption.
How do these things happen?
How is sodium,
for example,
reabsorbed so efficiently in
the proximal tubule?
Well, I'm going to give you a
simple example of that just so
that you have a way of thinking
about the mechanism,
but you're going to remember
that there's more going on than
just what I described.
Imagine that this is the
proximal tubule,
so a part of the tubule just
after Bowman's space,
where sodium concentration is
high inside the filtrate.
What's the concentration of
sodium in the filtrate right
after the glomerulus?
It's the same as the
concentration in plasma.
What's the concentration of
sodium inside cells that line
the tubule?
Well, like all cells these have
sodium potassium pumps and so
the concentration of sodium
inside these cells is low.
The intracellular concentration
of sodium is low.
High concentration here,
low concentration here,
so if this membrane is
permeable to sodium it's going
to diffuse from inside to
outside.
What would allow--does
sodium diffuse through
membranes?
Charged molecules don't diffuse
through membranes on their own,
not if it's just a lipid
bilayer.
What allows sodium to diffuse?
What kinds of structures allow
sodium to diffuse through a
lipid membrane?
Protein channels,
ion channels,
sodium channels--so there must
be sodium channels in these
membranes and there are,
and the sodium moves through.
Now, you have high sodium
inside or higher than before
because sodium can leak through
these channels,
but you have on this other
surface of the cell,
you have a lot of these sodium
potassium pumps.
These sodium potassium pumps
are constantly pumping sodium
out and bringing potassium,
sodium out, potassium in and
there's pumps here,
there's pumps here.
So, any molecules of sodium
that enter this side get
efficiently pumped out through
the other side.
The net effect of these two
processes, diffusion on this
boundary and active transport on
this boundary,
is that sodium molecules move
from inside the tube to outside
the tube.
Now, if sodium
concentration is high here where
is it going to go?
Well, there are blood vessels
up here and they're going to
reabsorb this sodium just by
simple diffusion processes as
well,
so blood that's flowing through
this region is going to take all
the extra sodium away.
The net effect here is that
sodium gets moved from--in this
filtrate, this urine back into
the blood.
Now, the property of these
cells, which allows this to
happen, is that the sodium
potassium pumps are only on this
surface,
they're not on this surface.
The sodium potassium pumps are
only on this surface and not on
this surface.
On this surface just diffusion
of sodium down its gradient is
the only thing that happens,
and on this surface that sodium
is moved out into the
interstitial space.
This is one example of the
kind of properties that cells of
the tubules use in order to
selectively move a particular
molecule from one side to the
other.
What are the properties that we
talked about?
Membranes are leaky,
membranes are leaky because
they have channels,
here's a leaky membrane here,
and membranes have active
transport systems that move
selectively ions from one side
to the other.
This is an example that shows
how that works with sodium,
there are systems that work
with all of the ions that we've
talked about,
not in exactly the same way but
with the same sorts of concepts.
I don't want to say too
much about this diagram.
I just show it here so that you
can look at it at your leisure
if that's what you would do with
your leisure time.
You could study this diagram
which just shows you something
about what kinds of transporters
are functioning in different
cells of the proximal tubule,
the ascending or descending
limb of Henle's Loop,
the distal convoluted tubule,
the collecting duct.
These are channels that allow
for selective movement of
certain kinds of molecules like
sodium, like glucose,
like bicarbonate and potassium.
This table is a little bit more
complicated than the one I
showed you before,
but just to try to put it all
into perspective again,
that the kidney because of
glomerular filtration produces
per 24 hours 26,
000 milliequivalents of sodium
are filtered and almost all of
those are reabsorbed,
only a few of them are excreted.
Now, if you happen to eat a
lot more salt on one day,
what would happen?
You would filter more,
you would reabsorb a little
less, and you would excrete that
balance.
You would filter more because
you would have eaten more salt
then you needed so more sodium
would appear in your blood than
normal.
The concentration would be
slightly higher in the plasma,
you'd filter more of it,
you'd reabsorb less of it,
and the result would be you
would excrete more.
The same thing with potassium
and with these other molecules
here, and interestingly,
what this shows is the
percentage of these molecules
that are reabsorbed.
Then, in this table here shows
you what part of the tubular
system that reabsorption takes
place, so you could think about
that if you wanted.
I want to just say one last
word about water balance and
this is just to illustrate the
concept of homeostasis that
we've been talking about for all
these ions before,
that you could think of your
body as a vessel where there are
inputs and output.
For water the input is mainly
the water that you drink or that
you've taken in food because
some foods contain high
quantities of water too.
For a normal individual you're
going to take about 2.1 L of
water in per day in food and
drink.
You synthesize some water
because some of the chemical
reactions that occur during
metabolism have water as a
byproduct, so you synthesize
some water.
Your overall daily intake is
about 2.3 L of water per day.
You have to get rid of that
water, because if you're taking
in water and you're not getting
rid of it then you're expanding
your volume.
You get rid of it in a variety
of ways, about a liter and a
half in urine,
almost a third of a liter
through your lungs because you
breathe in air that's relatively
dry,
you breathe out air that's very
humid.
If you take a glass plate and
you breathe out on it,
it gets foggy,
you could see water condense
because your breathe is much
more--has much more water in it
than the air around us,
so we lose actually quite a lot
of water that way.
Through sweat and other
activities you lose more water,
so that your daily loss
balances your daily intake.
Now, what if you drink more
water?
What if you drink--what if
you're--I know there's a lot of
water bottles in the room here.
A lot of you carry water around
with you and you drink water
constantly throughout the day,
what happens?
You drink more water than this,
if you ingest 3.1 L per water
then you've got to lose
3.1--you've got to lose 3.3 L of
water.
Normally what you lose in your
lungs and by sweat and other
mechanisms doesn't change,
what changes is the amount that
you use in urine.
You're all familiar with this,
if you drink more water one day
than you did the day before,
you're going to produce more
urine, go to the bathroom more
often.
I don't know another way to say
it--well, I do know.
I don't want to say it any
other way.
What if you--what if instead of
water you decided on another day
not to eat any salt?
You're not going to eat any
salt during the day what would
happen?
Well, you would need to
maintain your salt concentration
high, need to maintain the salt
concentration high.
Your kidney has to lose a
little bit of salt,
it can't recover 100% so if you
ate no salt at all,
you can't recover 100% of it
you're going to lose a little
bit of the salt through your
urine.
It can't recover 100% of the
salt, so you're going to lose a
little bit of salt through your
urine.
If you didn't eat any salt then
your sodium concentration is
going to drop,
it would want to drop.
Your body won't allow that to
happen, the kidneys won't allow
that to happen.
If it notices that you're
sodium concentration is going
down but you're not bringing any
more sodium in,
how else can it change the
concentration?
It could decrease the volume of
water in your body so it could
produce more watery urine,
or urine with more water in it.
Try this experiment,
don't eat any salt,
it means you probably can't go
to the dining hall but if you
don't eat any salt for a day you
will notice that you're
producing more urine.
If you weight yourself in the
morning and you weigh yourself
at night, your weight will go
down over the course of one day.
That's why it's easy to lose a
pound or two,
you can do that by just
restricting salt in your diet.
It's a nice example of how your
body--how the kidney in
particular senses what
concentrations are present in
your body and adjusts what it
can depending on what you're
eating in order to maintain
what's important.
What's important is the
concentration of extracellular
sodium has to be at the right
level so that your brain and
your heart can function
properly.
Okay, that's it for renal
physiology, in the section this
afternoon we'll talk about
dialysis.
Dialysis is the technology
developed by biomedical
engineers over the last century
that allows people to live
without normal kidney function
by performing some of these
essential functions outside the
body.